le fait que emmanuel macron se déporte
sur sa droite sur les questions
sécuritaires sur les questions
d'identité de rapport aux religions à
l'islam en particulier vient de du fait
que ces questions là sont les seuls sur
lesquels on peut 2d l'impression d'avoir
une prise elle est totalement factice
puisque de fait les quais ces questions
là ne sont pas réglés ça fait vingt ans
que ça s'enkystent mais ça permet de
tenir un discours qui est un discours en
apparence de volonté politique quand
bien même à côté on a abandonné toute
volonté politique sur les questions
économiques le problème c'est que je
pense qu'en fait contrairement à ce que
croient beaucoup d'hommes politiques qui
pratique ce jeu
les deux sont liés c'est à dire que les
la destruction de la communauté
nationale
là le parent par un phénomène à la fois
d'individualisme et de communautarisme
elle est aussi une conséquence de la
fragmentation des sociétés liées au
néolibéralisme c'est à dire que le
loonie le néolibéralisme à petit à petit
détruits les états-nations c'est même un
des projets du néolibéralisme de
considérer qu'il va falloir s'appuyer
sur des entité supranationale que ce
soit par exemple l'union européenne que
ce soit l'om c'est à dire des éléments
qui vont s'éloigner petit à petit de
l'échelle de l'état nation parce que
c'est à l'échelle de l'état nation plus
s'exerce la démocratie
[Musique]